[Music]
foreign
to the Thanksgiving holiday I must
discuss something that happened last
week actually it's two things both
occurred during the Q a portion of my
speech at Berkeley on Thursday night
there are two people who must be
considered candidates for cancellation
as a result of the Q a and since we've
run out of time for the week we have to
cover them both in today's daily
cancellation and decide who's the one
who should get canceled so first
we start with a man named Jacob who to
his credit actually uh had the guts to
confront me on on camera during the Q a
over the course of our what is a woman
College Tour stopping at six or seven
different schools there were only two or
three leftists in the whole time who
dared to debate me in person and most of
the rest stood outside screaming holding
signs eating the Bible
in at least one case anyway Jacob was
one of the select few though
unfortunately he squandered the
opportunity by retreating and taking
cover behind a desperate appeal to
Authority as they so often do here's how
that conversation began
why in your movies and your discussions
be selectively ignore and misrepresent
the recent burgeoning medical and
behavioral literature that demonstrates
uh that uh gender affirming care and
meds and similar medical interventions
demonstrate consistent improvements to
mental health suicidality and general
well-being
which study are those there are probably
like 30 Studies by this point all
produced in the last like 10 years or so
anybody can look them up on okay well
just here's here's the problem here's a
problem I'm not impressed
by just you saying a study no okay
because studies
fine well there could be 100 studies
there could be a thousand studies great
yeah and actually I have heard them have
you yes I have okay so here's I'll give
you one example I don't know if you can
give me an example but I'll give you one
example of a recent study that that uh
and this was just in the headlines it
said that uh it proved that um double
mastectomies for minor girls improves
their well-being
and this was a study and it was proven
peer-reviewed
then you read what they how they
actually conducted this study and you
find out that they that they interviewed
a very small selection of girls in one
region of the country all from the same
socioeconomic background and they did
their follow-up I think it was
three months later
and based on a follow-up a few months
later they've determined that oh yeah it
improves well-being
you see the problem here no I don't want
I don't know many but there are this is
the exception to the rule many people I
don't think it is use uh observate use
observational data
um uh with various follow-up from like
six months to five years to ten years
and they don't demonstrate what you
claim
well I just you can say the word study
but what I'm saying is when you look
them up okay great you can Google them
so he does a he's he's done a good bit
of of Googling he says
um and uh the only problem is that as is
usually the case when they start
babbling on about studies he cannot give
any specific examples which means that
he cannot defend the methodology used in
these studies all he knows is that the
studies were done and though he doesn't
know exactly what they say he knows that
whatever they say they vindicate
whatever he already thought before he
read the studies though he actually
didn't read them to begin with so to
review he brought up studies
but I'm the only one in the conversation
who could speak with any specificity
about any of the studies that he brought
up so the conversation continued until
um I got to what I think is the most
important Point here let's listen
how do you think they would have
large-scale long-term studies about the
effects of these drugs and these
surgeries on children when we only
started doing it to children at a large
scale a few years ago
so how could that even exist yeah I
think scale is probably one of the more
prevalent challenges of these studies
okay so we're already hearing that there
are challenges in these studies every
study has challenges like any scientific
truth like all of the scientific truth
that we take for granted today they're
built on methodologies that
fundamentally have flaws like if you
want to make a specific critique you can
do that if you're talking about I just
did well if you're talking about sample
size they're very well demonstrated
statistical results that you don't need
10 000 people to get like a significant
a statistically significant yes you do
yeah here's absolutely not it's like a
very basic statistic Jacob here's Jacob
sample size greater than a thousand that
can uh like that has very nice
asymptotic properties like Jacob here's
here's what I know
if you want to even begin to claim that
a study has proven
that castrating and sterilizing little
boys helps them in the long run then you
would need to have a large sample size
of children who've gone through these
procedures and we've checked back with
them in adulthood to see how they're
doing those studies do not exist they
can't exist because we weren't doing
this to kids at anywhere near this scale
even five years ago let alone ten years
ago what that tells us Jacob is that the
kids we have right now they are the
sample okay they are the experiments we
are we are experimenting on children
right now
so right why aren't there any reliable
studies because the study is happening
right now today and the sample size is
an entire generation of kids
um Jacob and I continued for another
several minutes of course uh as I point
out to him later in the discussion the
whole focus on studies is a distraction
we don't need permission from a study to
arrive at certain common sense
conclusions one of those conclusions
that is that it is wrong to perform
cosmetic surgery on the sex organs of
children
and it's wrong to give them medically
unnecessary drugs that will permanently
hamper and destroy their physical
development so we can talk about the
studies and I can point out as I did
that the methodologies are flawed Beyond
repair but the truth is that there is no
study that would ever convince me that
we should castrate a child okay like
when someone asks me should we castrate
children I don't say well let me check
to see what the studies say I I just I
can say no to that the same way that if
you ask me should we shoot a child in
the head I would say
no and if you do you should be shot in
the head I don't need to check the
studies for that either directly and
intentionally harming children in these
barbaric ways is wrong
so he could produce a study with a
sample size of 50 000 which includes
follow-ups over the course of 30 years I
mean he can't because again that study
doesn't exist
but even if it did it would not move me
even one inch towards accepting or
supporting the physical mutilation of
children
I don't check with academics before
deciding whether I oppose child abuse I
just oppose it and I always will and
nothing can ever change that as I tried
to explain
to Jacob eventually he just walked away
from the from the microphone when he had
enough I guess
so does Jacob deserve to be canceled
perhaps
but unfortunately someone else stepped
forward later on in the Q a who is even
more deserving of the cancellation
and that person is me uh
the time has come for the chancellor to
be canceled I have been slain by my own
cancellation sword
because of this
hello so I just saw people shouting in
like a bunch of barricades so I thought
it was fun to come here I didn't really
know who you were so before it started I
Googled you on Wikipedia I scrolled down
to the controversy section and it said
you said anime was satanic so I was one
Matt
I was wondering if I bought your book
would you watch a season of any anime
with me
why How's that gonna work
um
Zoom
okay I hate Zoom meetings and I hate
anime now you want me to combine the two
okay okay and what am I getting out of
this I buy your book one book you gotta
buy a lot more books you have to buy
about about 100 books to make that worth
it so if we started a GoFundMe to buy a
hundred books you would live stream you
watching a season of anime
yes okay
all right don't all right
[Applause]
I am indeed the stupidest man on earth
and the worst deal maker in history
Donald Trump would be ashamed why did I
agree to that to an entire season of
anime an entire season not just one
episode a season
and instead of asking for like a
thousand books or ten thousand I agree
to this torture for a measly 100 books
that that was by far the worst
negotiation I've ever witnessed I watch
and think who is this [ __ ] and then I
realize that the [ __ ] is me and I'm
filled not only with Dread but also
shame
I can only say it's a good thing that I
use a real estate agent instead of
making real estate deals on my own I'm
apparently the kind of guy who would
sell my house for like 50 bucks in a
Wendy's gift card only this is much
worse because as I've already
established anime is satanic so watching
an entire season of it certainly means
that I will become demonically possessed
so I have sold my soul here I've sold it
for a few books
I could have just done a like a hit on
Tucker Carlson you know and sold more
books than that
100 books
what what was I thinking I was not
thinking at all apparently
or or my thinking was impaired I was at
Berkeley after all maybe I was high from
all the second hand weed smoke in the
air maybe just two days in San Francisco
was enough to cause mental illness
I don't know how to explain it
now the good news is that technically
I never said when I would watch the
anime those details were never specified
I could schedule the live stream session
for like sometime in the year 2035 and I
would be I would not be violating the
terms of the deal if I did that
but the bad news is that apparently this
guy did already start the GoFundMe and
has raised almost immediately raised two
thousand dollars to buy the books so I I
had to the reason you might be asking
like why am I bringing this up now well
I held off on playing this clip in fact
I wasn't going to play it at all at all
because I was hoping that if I didn't
promote it or talk about it he wouldn't
be able to raise the funds because how
is he going to do that but um this has
taken on a life of its own and I am now
being swept along helplessly by the
current
and my destination is an entire season
of anime
and then as a result the loss of my
Eternal Soul I am a condemned man
condemned by my own suicidal negotiation
tactics
so all I can do now is call on the sweet
baby gang
in this time of Thanksgiving
to come to my Aid
and and tell me which anime has the
shortest episodes and shortest Seasons
ideally I'm talking about like I wanted
an anime that has three minute episodes
and three episodes per season
if such anime exists
and if it doesn't exist I need one of
you to make one okay I need this is this
this is the situation we're in right I'm
calling in a favor I am mobilizing sweet
baby gang I need you to make an anime
and put it on YouTube
season one of whatever thing anime
and and I'll and I'll watch it
only you can save me now
I certainly cannot save myself
because the day has finally arrived
when I must say that I am
canceled
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you uh on Monday have a great
Thanksgiving Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]